britains economic recovery is on track  on track on track a rebalancing of our  economy rebalance the economy  rebalancing of the economy rebalancing  protect Britain from this debt storm  debt storm debt storm debt storm  it is a hard road it is a hard road is  hard but we are making progress making  progress we are making program  taking the difficult decisions more  difficult decisions taking the difficult  decisions very difficult decisions take  the difficult decisions difficult  decisions we have taken difficult  decisions we fix that roof when the sun  is shining we will fix the roof when the  sun is shining is working long-term  economic plan long-term economic plan a  long-term economic plan long-term  economic plan than you hoped